hello reject nation it's Greg Alva here
remember Lauren Francesca from the
channel I want my Lauren she's back
today people I wanted to mention that I
am the lead star of her new webseries I
have a small as a new webseries out
called a plan and my brother Jeb Eco and
I make a guest appearance in there you
guys should go check it out I think
we're gonna do a reaction for it on this
channel because I haven't seen it yet
that's the kind of friend I am I like to
not watch things my friends do but I'll
watch it here today with you later on
before that though have you seen the
movie showgirls Lauren of course of
course says of course the showgirls okay
yeah you know I've never seen Saved by
the Bell
are you kidding but I've seen showgirls
no but when I saw showgirls and made me
want to watch they by the belt but I
heard there's a lot less nudity and say
by the belt
well anyway there's an Austrian out for
showgirls let her know why they're doing
this one but screw it let's check it out
we both know John Bailey yeah
before fifty Shades of Grey
that's why accessible internet porn the
sexiest thing you could see this great
was probably not you know as a classic
orders that we'd watch on music it'd
yeah to get a wide release
banned by the highest paid screenwriter
directed by the guy who made Basic
Instinct and hated by nearly everyone
who was alive at the time anything being
played off I didn't care for the well I
didn't either
you remember Elizabeth Berkeley from
Seabury hands now she's all grown up and
she's bringing the same energy she
brought to the caffeine pills episode
[Music]
watch her act balls to the wall no
matter what's happening in the Z whether
it's dancing dancing even harder just
anything really she'll chew the scenery
like a rabid dog then lick it afterwards
for good measure
[Music]
and fun or insane journey from the sea
strip clubs at the bottom to the bizarre
volcano acrobat shows at the top with
only one person crazy do you like sex
[Laughter]
between the particularly aggressive fish
[Music]
this has to have the
[Laughter]
to the streets Wow the only thing
funnier than watching showgirls watching
with the isolated audio we are the as
guardians of the galaxy transition I the
future
my nephew wanted to be Batman Wow Wow
however you mean you saw showgirls I
don't even think I was allowed to watch
the whole movie because I'm what I'm
looking at the the parts of it I don't
even remember those scenes I remember
most of them yeah I watched that movie
when I was six years old yeah I was a
little too young to watch it I think I
think this was my introduction to the
closest thing to pornography back then
my dad had a VHS copy no okay what's
worse than that he had a copy not cuz he
bought a VHS copy he had a copy because
he rented it and then copied it onto a
VHS and labeled it big all caps
showgirls and then I watched this movie
it was an exciting film for me at the
time
I couldn't my body hadn't developed
enough yet to do certain things to
certain scenes but I'll tell you I
wanted to man she was pretty hot man
she's pretty hot she still look like
that I don't know let's look her up
oh she looks great she's like a hot milf
right there
oh snap this looks like she has some
Botox and stuff but who cares she looks
awesome so this movie inspire you no
really I mean it looks like an awesome
movie but there's a lot of boobs
what's wrong with that that movie didn't
want to make you grow up and become a
Vegas showgirl like all the little girls
I knew when I was a kid yeah we all
watched showgirls first come here I got
here you're like you know words gonna
love reactor I'm sorry it's what you
requested I just got to do that you know
this movie is a terrible terrible film
it's one of those movies too that a lot
of people will go to watch it because of
all the nudity and sex and whatever you
end up just being so immune to it by the
time that there's something's happening
you're just like it's not even a turn-on
anymore it's not even hot although that
lap dancing a lap dancing always wanted
me to go to the strip what made me want
to go strip him and I'll tell you the
one thing Laura Francesca never had a
lap dance like that I honestly feel very
sorry for elizabeth berkley because she
was on Saved by the Bell which is a hit
show and then she does this movie from
like an acclaimed director a claim
writer she probably thought this was her
big shot right that this was gonna be
her opportunity make it in the big
leagues in Hollywood like screw it yeah
I'll take the dance lessons I'll show my
vagina and boobs off in a movie who
cares did she show her vagina yeah you
see her vagina yeah when she does a lot
dancing you really should watch it it's
a good scene yeah sure it's more the
more powerful scenes I've seen in recent
memory I watched this last week this
feel terrible for her because she like
bared all that film and she really gave
like an emotional performance or try to
I just feel terrible for someone to go
all out like that and to just have her
career tanked because of it you think it
tanked because of it because it's a
terrible film it's cliche it's cheesy
there's nothing unique and the acting is
bad which makes for a great honest
trailer but you watch it a lot right
I've seen it like maybe I don't know
I've seen certain scenes a lot from
beginning to end
it's hard to skip to certain scenes on a
VHS player there's no scene selection on
that alright it's a lot of stop rewind
stop fast-forward whatever guys listen
subscribe to the real rejects subscribe
to screen junkies while you're at it
click that notification bell don't worry
none of them do anything what I want to
tell you though is make sure to check
out Lauren's webseries Apple and it's in
the description box I'm in the first
episode I am what you call a scene
stealer I'm what you call like wow I
should have played Laurens across I get
I want it you know was your director
wouldn't let me get fully naked and when
I was like just let me do it and he's
like no one wants to see that I was like
dude you don't know people everyone
wants to see me naked
ultimately we didn't do it no no I have
nothing impressive going on
no cuz it's a really embarrassing sight
for me oh geez
[Laughter]